it's andrew what's up brother
hey this is good to see y'all um
i have a bit of a question although i
may just be justifying it over
complicating
so
when it comes
when it comes to dealing with women and
a lot of the times it seems like it only
focuses around sex sex sex and trying to
basically just having game but then
[Music]
from what i can see i see everything
from jack donovan's approach that it's
kind of like sex is just sex with uh
sex without kids essentially is just
glorified masturbation
so
i'm kind of curious what y'all's
thoughts are on that and
what's
what's your primary focus is when it
comes to that is it
hey i'm just kind of curious to know
what your thoughts are
so i'm not totally clear on your
questions so let me let me just re
rephrase it to you to get to sort of
clarify i have a magic wand i can wave
it it's going to solve your question and
offer clarity what are you stuck on
exactly
basically it's kind of just basically
just searching for sex is very vapid
doesn't seem to have any pay off
it's just glorified masturbation so then
surgery no more just because somebody's
searching for more out of it got it but
i mean like just because somebody says
something and i think there's a lot of
people out there that will
complicate life and justify why so i
mean like you kind of already knew that
you're sort of you know like heading
there and it's like
they'll they'll have an opinion and say
something like well sex is just
glorified masturbation okay well
i like jack donovan he's a friend of
mine i've met him several times and i'll
probably have him on a future podcast
again he writes great books um he's by
the way right so it's not and he's
really not looking for a family either
you know from what i understand um the
the
thing about certain statements is if you
marry yourself to them and you take them
hook line and sinker it's like um i did
this post on my youtube you know
community page and then i uh dropped a
link to the interview that i did with
sean stevenson as well and he and he had
this statement he said never believe a
prediction that doesn't empower you
right and the thing about sex that you
got to understand andrew is it's
not just about reproduction throughout
the entire animal kingdom most animals
only have sex to make babies
humans are probably the most you know
aside from dolphins and and some some
primates like the more promiscuous ones
um sex is used for
pair bonding for
transactions for socializing for
social hierarchy movements there's all
kinds of maneuver for fun for pleasure
obviously right like it's not just to
make babies when it comes to humans so
um in fact i put the stats in my book i
think it's something like you know for
every pregnancy humans will have sex
like over a thousand times right whereas
in the animal kingdom it's like 10 to 15
times
okay i don't remember that part
specifically i have read your book i
just don't remember that specifically
yeah did that offer the clarity that you
needed uh yeah oh it is it's a long it's
along the lines of what i was what i was
wondering just
i appreciate the clarity thank you like
i i i've got a question too
um because i've had a lot of guys
looking for coaching lately saying that
like they have a mental roadblock like
they they insert an excuse almost as to
why they should hold themselves back and
i realize that a lot of guys are in this
problem because a lot of girls i'm with
have this problem too like i'll notice
like they're starting to enjoy
themselves and they'll hold themselves
back especially like younger more
inexperienced girls and a lot of guys do
the same thing is it like a mental
roadblock that you're trying to find a
justification for maybe holding yourself
back and not enjoying the act as much as
you would or
you fall in maybe a second camper like
you've already had so much where you're
like okay i'm kind of looking for more
because i got to that point too and now
i'm like all right really sex is a
pre-qualifier to know if like the girl
is cool like like you got you got to
smash as fast as possible to get her
into your frame that bedroom's the last
bastion of masculinity but once you're
able to like push her boundaries and
actually like have that shared
experience with her then you build that
trust factor you have those hormones
flowing to you and her then you build
that closeness that interconnectedness
and at that point she's much more
receptive and much more forthcoming into
coming into your frame so those are like
kind of the two camps i see guys asking
those questions fall into do you
identify with either of those or am i
kind of off base
no you're not off base it's
uh what is it recently i'm very young as
you all can probably see i'm about 25.
i'm trying to i'm finally getting to the
point now where
i can get basically girls whenever i
want to and
it's kind of i get bored very quickly
with it because it seems like it's just
that's it move on okay whatever and
there's kind of nothing left so it's
just like okay there has to be more to
this and so i've gotten very apathetic
to it so i'm trying so i'm trying to
figure out if it's
are you just focused on racking up a
notch cam
no
i've gotten to the point now where i
don't really care who it is that i'm
with what girl that is that i'm with i
only care about
you want intimate kids
well if you want to have kids and then
what you're going to start to look for
is you look for a woman that's good
mother stock right which means that
you're gonna have to spend some time
with her over a couple years to see what
she's really all about
right to see what she does when stress
is applied to the relationship
uh because women you know can act you
know if they like you especially
and you know like i mentioned earlier
you know you made a check and you like
heavy metal and she doesn't like heavy
metal she'll probably start liking heavy
metal right so it's like
you want to see if she's truthfully like
as sordid as she really is if she
doesn't have red flags or if she's
acting
so i mean if your longer term goal is
later on down the road if you're 25 you
shouldn't really be worrying about this
right now like this is probably
something i'd be looking at um closer to
like late 20s maybe even 30s
but
right now that like the dynamics should
be forced on
chase excellence make bank you know set
the foundation for your life understand
female nature be captivating you know
build a interesting life so that you're
not boring you know you don't get bored
usually stuff like that
and then you know just date women and if
there's a woman that like really
you know like i always say spin plates
let the cream rise to the top if you
want to have a family then you know pick
that one if that's what you want to do
so basically already go for complicating
don't need to rush in don't need to rush
so much
yeah it's like whatever man like you
know if you actually spend
when you're not having sex and just like
go and have a coffee with her and get
like a baked good and just kind of sit
there and you know just shoot the [ __ ]
right like it doesn't have to be like
smashing all the time
yeah keep
keep
one of my
things i do for screening purposes
uh and this is just to find out what
women are into i'll say um who held
alexander's uh left flank at the battle
of gorgamela okay just to test out
whether they're into greek and roman
history like me and just
you know
you have a problem that 90 of the men
that we're encountering nowadays do not
have bro so go get into bitcoin or take
up a hobby start doing woodturning or
learning to cook or something because if
it's raining on you
get get
that's why i joined the group some other
i became a classical f boy i'm like all
right like i don't have this problem in
my life anymore
what else is there and then you know i
was like well i kind of need higher
quality guy friends and actually i look
more forward to coming onto these shows
and hanging out with i hang out with all
these guys in real life like these are
my friends now and i look way more
forward to that and then now like
even now like these last couple actually
most of the streams there's a girl in
the background you know doing whatever
but i just kind of like no here's my day
here's what i do here's what i'm about
if you want to stay in the background
that's fine if you want to take off like
cool too but they cut like
i'm set on my life on my purpose i do
what it is i want to do when i want to
do it how i want to do it and they're
just along for the ride and they can
they can jump off not on and off the
roller coaster whenever they want you
know which we have some rules like don't
poison the wealth obviously but yeah and
again keep in mind that exchange of of
energy right because again when you're
getting physically intimate with someone
there is that type of exchange and
transfer so if you're just in that class
crack crack rack then suddenly like
you're just kind of absorbing everything
right like you're imparting some but
you're absorbing a lot um so yeah like
one of the interest most interesting
experience i had was when i was
simultaneously going out and hooking up
with 14 girls at once was all 14 of
those girls were actually girls that i
genuinely liked and cared about and
would enjoy their company and all could
have had some type of long-term
potential so in a lot of senses i almost
felt like superman where i was like oh
my gosh like there's this overabundance
of like possibilities
did you say 14 girls yeah 14. yeah dude
that's yeah that place
you're a glutton for punishment if you
run 14 at a time yeah that was really
fine
range
yeah that was absolute craziest i ever
did but it was it was 20 20 why there's
nothing else to do right
so you know then i mean yeah normally
right trying to keep it somewhere
between like the two to three there's
like seven days in a week like you can
basically like either gotta double them
up daily
i got some i got stories from that year
oh dude okay all right well we'll talk
about that but yeah yeah we'll talk
offline but you know don't join us on
mob's show afterwards and we can i'll
come on i'll come with the show
afterwards actually yeah um yeah i'm not
talking about
when you got that energy right kind of
cycling through um you know uh if you
have like you know two or three of them
that are just like a really bad negative
kind of energy all right cool you might
get the the notch count but that energy
gets into you right yeah so you want to
be careful with like hey who are you
you know inviting into sharing that most
intimate of amd experiences with
and also pay attention to how your
energy interacts with her so like like i
i get to the point where like yeah
before when i was running up the notch
count it's just like literally like once
penetration occurred in my head okay
this is over what's next and i was
always thinking it's like how a fat kid
thinks like like when i was obese it was
always like i'm eating but i'm thinking
about the next meal like that's kind of
an addiction and a compulsion at that
point so for me i was like all right
jiren let's take it back let's slow down
and now like even in the actual act like
usually usually act one like you know
the girl's excited there's tension
you're excited too it's a new partner
you're feeling them out it's fun the
second act like it's kind of like all
right try to fill out her boundary c
like what she's about and the third for
me is usually really intimate like we
slow it down like a really slow and it's
like it's a deeper deeper connection
that's after you've built trust and you
know actually had the conversations like
oh what does your day look like what do
you do what are your goals and
aspirations like you'll feel her come
into you and that's the point for me
like that's the point now that my new
objective is where i'm like all right
like i've got this girl like she's all
about me and you can feel it like she
merges into you yes so so in the bedroom
like try to set new obstacles or new
goals it a lot of guys like oh you know
i gotta be like you gotta do crazy kinky
stuff but you're like you can go the
slower route too and like like all right
i want to create like an actual physical
emotional whatever bond with this girl
and and again it's all about bringing
the best out of her and bringing the
best out of you and that's that's where
that intimacy occurs which i think is
what a lot of guys are really after they
think that's the right answer but then
they're like oh they're right there's
not much to it seriously you should have
that lined up right before you're
getting to that point right you want to
have the good things in place before
right yeah before and there's ways it's
a pre-qualifier for a lot of yeah you
can speed up that process for sure
all right thanks andrew
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you